the resistance takes many forms and and
to this point of
of the tactile and the mystical another
thing that i really
love about it is that
what you write about is so rooted in in
in very practical takeaways like look
you've got to create ritual you got to
create habits you got to be
your own self-disciplinarian you have to
have these rules and here's how you set
up your calendar
and erect healthy boundaries to protect
that thing that's most precious to you
but when you do those things you provide
the space
for the muse to enter and for you to
connect with the collective unconscious
so that you
are are not necessarily writing or
whatever it is you're creating but
really acting as a channel
for the best version of who you are to
reveal itself to you
so talk a little bit about that balance
between the practical and the mystical
that's abs absolutely true and then this
must be in
ultra fitness events too i mean when you
write about this
that it's when you get to that point of
you know the third day of running around
hawaii or whatever
whatever it is you know your third iron
man in in hawaii
that uh you start uh you know getting
really deeply into yourself right
you're in a whole other level but the
way that you get there
is through the mundane through the
training through one foot in front of
another
and and all of the uh the discipline and
and the ritual that goes into that but
it is
the creative process to me is my
experience
is that it's it's a two-sided thing
on the one hand there is the the
practical
the blue collar aspect of the thing you
have to show up every morning
you have to you know have have habits
that reinforce what you're doing
you have to work every day just like a
blue collar guy with a whistle
the factory you know and but at the same
time
once you sort of get rolling and it's
really like
yoga right where where the whole concept
of yoga is that
you use the body to get to the spirit
right
to as as you get deeper and deeper and
deeper into a particular pose
things start to happen inside you and
the same thing certainly in writing and
songwriting and things like that that
once
the the mundane has been taken care of
you know the floor has been swept
the table's been cleaned and you're
actually sitting down there hour one
hour two hour three and you know this
rich pretty soon
you know things start to happen um
ideas start coming to you there is a
muse there is a higher
level and your intention
and your integrity and your work your
labor your sweat
to go for that higher level gets
rewarded and the higher level does come
down to you
and you know it's a common place to say
that
the best pages i've ever written i don't
remember writing them at all
you know um and that's not completely
true because you are
you know you are kind of there you're
doing your thing it isn't just
a magical thing but you get there
through
through the depth of of commitment and
um of of aspiration and
and of intensity and another thing you
know while i'm blathering on here about
this stuff no i love it
keep going but uh one of the things that
i hate about this era today the
internet era the social media era
is it's so surface it's so superficial
it rewards
absolute superficiality right we go from
one
click bait thing to another we never
delve into anything
and kind of if there is a secret to
creativity
or to you know ultra fitness or anything
like that
it's it's depth it's the opposite it's
kind of
you know after hour one is different
than after
10 minutes and after hour two is
different than after hour one
and and so on if you're if as a writer
as you start getting into a scene or
something that you're working on
you know as you get level level level
down
things start coming you just it's and
it's not even mystical it's just sort of
like well gee that guy that i had
standing in the corner
that guy should come out here and say
something you know and
and then oh my god that really makes it
happen whereas you wouldn't have thought
of that
the first 10 minutes into the right into
the operation yeah you gotta you gotta
blast out all the cobwebs and create
that
open space that um allows for that to
come in
and as a writer that's what you live for
so the structure
the rigor that you put in and the
discipline is solely to create that open
space
for those glimpses yeah to enter right
yeah that's true like
you know when i first read the war of
art we the culture was very different
now the level to which we're enticed by
distraction is a thousand-fold what it
was
a decade ago let alone two decades ago
which i think
in some regard makes your work more
urgent right
if we can uh identify an optimistic
um vein in all of this it's that we're
becoming more aware
of how distracted we are at the same
time that we've become
more powerless right to right you know
defend against it
yeah but we're having conversations
about that and we're having
conversations with our kids about that
because
we feel ourselves being pulled um
you know into our phones in a way that
that
you know we realize is alarming and
it's become incumbent upon of all all of
us
to exert a little bit more a lot more
self-discipline
around what's important to ourselves so
that we can carve that out and
for many for most and i found myself in
this place it's a
losing battle you're you're competing
with
you know computer engineers who've
studied psychology and know exactly
what to dangle in front of you to keep
you
on that lower plane and prevent you from
ascending
to your potential you know i've always
said you know if
if resistance is a real force and it is
and it's out there
i always have said if you want to make a
billion dollars
invent something that lets people yield
to their resistance
and the internet and social media that's
it they invented it
that's you know everything that we want
that the distraction that's put in front
of us the click bait that's put in front
of us
feeds into this existing force that's
right that's there already
that wants to distract us from our own
whatever our own calling is right inside
here
and so i don't think there's any real
way around it other than to sort of
block it out somehow you know just
turn it off you know go away from it
somehow
i don't think you can you can dally in
that world and defeat it it's too
powerful right
um right but you've i mean you've
you're you know you're on social media
and you've got this website that's
pretty robust and
educational and it's got tons of content
you did this
video series on on you know the warrior
ethos that's up there so
you know you're you're you're
participating but i suspect that
you have pretty good rules around when
you engage that's true but i'm also a
little bit like what you were saying
about the podcast
you know that's kind of that stuff is a
little easier to do and i
actually need to crack the whip over
myself i've got a book
that's waiting to go and that i'm kind
of uh
that i'm kind of avoiding at the moment
too yeah oh no another one that you're
working on right now
yeah another one i'm working on now yeah
[Music]
you